so hi everybody I'm Michelle the rupess
Demonte nice to see so many people
interested in micro-services it's fun to
say microservices I have a company
called salon so we do a lot of projects
for Amazon a sure the various platforms
for the last few years now we've been
building a practice around this stuff
and one of the things we do a lot is we
build message based architectures for
you know large scale organizations that
are building micro services and a lot of
the reason behind that I'm going to talk
about in this talk and give you some of
the motivations for putting in the elbow
grease that it takes to go this route
because obviously it does create another
layer of things you have to care for
right but there's a lot of benefits on
the other side so I hope to inspire you
to you know think about whether or not
this fits what you might be doing okay
and so with that let's get started let
me introduce you to our hello world
today hello world today consists of you
know browser-based apps maybe they could
be server-side maybe they could be spas
with a back-end for front-end or BFF API
people love to say that mobile apps that
have back-end api's shared api's that
might go across all of them you have
partner api's that might be you know
shared for third parties so maybe we
need a crook protect some of those
things with api gateways throttling
governing usage possibly license keys
that we would distribute and manage so
sometimes we have api gateways in the
middle of that we've got back-end API s
that might be protecting or accessing
the business data on the backend and
then we've got back in processing so
there's a lot going on in your you know
typical app today all these poor people
that get out of school and now they face
this instead of one big thing right so
this is hello world and this is also the
new monolith because the monolith
basically is this but with huge data
back-end obviously
perfectly coupled to all of the api's
and applications that you're serving and
in addition a lot of potential shared
code across all of these things so that
when we update things we're not really
sure what we might break because it kind
of all glues together a big ball of mud
right
it looks nice in a picture till you you
know glue it all together so this is
what we face and this is what we're
trying to get away from when we do a
micro-services architecture so the idea
is you know right now hello world and
you know your everyday app is already
complicated we have distributed systems
out of the gates you're dealing with API
is you're dealing with server-side scale
you're dealing with um you know dealing
with connections and how many concurrent
requests can I handle all these things
in an Internet and cloud first world
right so what is it if I add a couple of
micro services in the middle right I
take my api's I make them more granular
more manageable ID couple the glue you
know break it apart into a manageable
set of you know projects that can be in
isolation deployed so the idea behind
micro services gives me a way to
hopefully achieve the dream right where
I can have isolated data behind each of
the services so that they own their own
data back-end so that when I do updates
to the schema or anything else
I'm only updating that one piece so that
when the UI is that call those api's
need to be updated I'm not necessarily
impacting the rest of the system that's
the idea that's where we want to go
right so the micro service is a dream is
that we can have new features everywhere
quickly rapidly please the business
right anytime we want to do an update we
update it seamlessly no impact to
anybody else and we get you know our
wish which is frequent updates without
impact and then we do the release and
we're not so worried about sweating with
roll back and roll forward and if we do
have to do that it's a small isolated
piece we're dealing with right and what
we're leveraging is the self-healing
nature of the container platforms so
that if something is failing something
is not working it will try to self heal
it will try to restart and hopefully
we've built resiliency into the client
consumers of those api's that might have
a glitch for a moment and then they will
do retries and you
use circuit breaker techniques to fail
fast but gracefully right so we're
hoping for that we're hoping for more
visibility into production so what we
want is you know visibility into our
logs we want to debug with our logs we
want to be able to solve problems
without having to call developers to
look at code we want to know more about
what's going on in the system as a whole
we want dashboards right we have to do
all these things already in a
microservices architecture to be
successful because there's an awful lot
of moving parts we're managing and if
you don't have that visibility you just
can't be successful right at the end of
the day the goal is not just to have
more moving parts and you know deal with
the complexities or the the need to add
more instrumentation and dashboards to
manage that we're not doing it just for
fun right ultimately we're still doing
it for the business right we're doing it
because they want to introduce features
that will sell more services or new
features that will keep customers happy
right we want to reduce support calls we
want to release more and more and then
we have the happy executive dance right
so enter the issue we still have to
solve with micro services right which is
distributed data and the idea of
different API is trying to own their own
data how do we deal with you know
potential shared data stores for
different parts of the system right we
still have to solve that problem and
that's an age-old problem it's not new
it's a problem that we had in the SOA
days right so take yourself back about
15 years you know we had the
introduction of SOA and you know a SOA
is promise was that every service owned
its own data right so we had the
Enterprise Architect view of this was
that we would have you know ERP systems
and CRM systems and CMS systems and you
know other acronyms and the idea was
that an Enterprise Architect would say
hey I need to integrate these systems to
create workflows for the business right
and how they would do that is maybe they
would build integrations on top but
those integrations always were true to
the SOA boundaries right we would call
the services to
year or the integrations here of those
apps so the apps were intended to be
built as soas right so that again the
services on the data you never come in
from any other direction right and so
the principles of SOA guided us that
when we build applications we're
supposed to follow those principles as
well not just the Enterprise Architect
view but the solution architects you the
problem is this didn't always work right
because the interface of those services
would not do what we need it or they'd
suck is a shorter way to say that and
then I would have to go into the backend
or somebody would build data sinks and
build aggregates and produce new views
into that data for the reporting of the
rest of the company so we didn't always
go through the service boundary because
we just didn't always have that Liberty
right so there's that now when we go
from Enterprise Architect view to the
solution architect view I remember
struggling with this so many times right
back in the days of wucf and SOA and
building solutions and wanting to stay
pure to the SOA principles and practices
right and what we wanted to do is build
our applications with these beautiful
well-defined boundaries and services
contracts that governed how you access
the data behind the service right the
arrows always point down never sideways
never up right nice clean architecture
and we would have multiple services
behind the application each owning their
own data beautiful right
but the problem is sometimes customers
and orders need to relate to one another
so you couldn't just have a customer
service and an order service and so on
you had to have some crossover right
where the query had to cross two or
three or other domains if you will right
and so we would end up crossing the
boundaries on the data layer even though
we had a well-defined interface I want
the customers and their orders so we
would end up you know making a query in
the back that couples the data right and
then we started building the the new
monolith so this problem was attempted
to be resolved right with data services
right so the OData service the idea was
he
the dream now we'll have another layer
of services that we query and now if I
want to you know bring across data I
call a service here and I'm still
following SOA principles now because I'm
calling a service that owns its own data
there you go
but that didn't perform right so now
we've got a performance problem we've
got to aggregate information and it's
simply not going to go well so we ended
up going back to this and saying well
you know basically who cares so I'm
gonna go back and I'm gonna cross at the
backend so that my system performs and
we'll just take the hit on the SOA
principles Thanks
so our goals to maintain those
principles maybe SOA was really more for
the Enterprise Architect at that time
right it was really hard to do that in a
solution and I think that micro services
and in general there's a lot of a few
ways you can approach the distributed
data issue this problem right one is we
can have two-phase commit
across distributed data stores across
services if you're actually using
back-in-the-day SOA had you know
distributed transactions over XML no
thanks we tried it was an attempt yes
so two-phase commit is one way to deal
with observer the data we've got
compensating operations to deal with
distributed data if you want to keep
pure to your boundaries and then we got
eventual consistency and in a micro
services solution you know you'll
probably see a lot of people talking
about eventual consistency as a practice
and when we embrace that messaging goes
very nice with that hand-in-hand so
that's not to say that everybody in this
room is going to do everything eventual
consistency but I wanted to debunk a few
myths we've certainly had our share of
customers that were skeptical about
doing eventual consistency part of the
reason is because they've just done it
badly in the past it happens right the
system was a mess anyways and then they
tried to do eventual consistency on stop
on top of something that was already a
mess and so they didn't have a pattern
to follow clearly across the solution or
across the apps they're building so it
became a bit chaotic oh let's throw some
messages over here and that'll work but
there was no structure behind it no
design right and so the answer to this
is not he
let's throw a bunch of messages in and
get some eventual consistency the answer
is you have to design it so if you're
going to embrace eventual consistency it
is a design pattern and it involves
having some practices that go alongside
possibly messaging so that's what I'm
going to talk about okay so when we
think about micro-services and eventual
consistency what I think about is let's
have these services that own their own
data back-end right and when we need to
update something in one of the services
and propagate a value into another like
say I have a ledger and I write a value
like I've withdrawn or deposited and I
need the total balance to get over to
say my you know account record that's
somewhere else so let's add the balance
to the main service where the
transaction happens and let's make it
eventually consistent that my total
balance shows on my dashboard and what
is eventual consistent mean right it
doesn't mean I'm gonna wait an hour or a
day it should mean I'm waiting you know
sub-second
or within a few seconds SLA just like
any other request in my system if I've
done it right and yes things can go
wrong just like your API is can be down
just like the system can slow when you
have you know some sort of extra load on
the system he likes the idea and so you
know what we're looking for is the same
as always we would get with requests
patterns right and that means we need to
have a healthy system that manages load
well and that scales well and that's
partitioned well so we have to consider
all those things when we do this as well
so eventual consistency just means I'm
gonna have a primary service who owns
the data and I'm gonna project somehow
maybe with messages the result of that
change and with a few ways we can
approach that which I'll talk about in a
minute um the other thing we might do is
have aggregate views right so I need a
completely new view of the data some
sort of reporting or again you know
could be anything so to get to this we
have to do design right and so you have
to be able to go through your
microservices design first with the
belief that you can do this because when
we start looking at document databases
how many people tried to use
database when they first came out anyone
heck no no three people cool well so I
knew a guy who did that and later
admitted a year and a half later that
they shouldn't have done that with their
startup why they weren't building a
microservices solution they were
building a solution that was really just
your traditional web app API single
back-end and this is you know going back
probably five years right before it was
really popular to think micro services
and so what they did is they spent about
a year-and-a-half building something
that they could have had done in three
months why because they had to go
through all the query patterns to help
them understand the best way to optimize
the use of the target document store and
it's really hard to work with a document
store for an entire system that's
typically relational and turn it into a
fully document store system if you're
not thinking in micro services so they
spent a long time redoing and redoing
and realizing that the way they needed
to query the data across the whole
system wasn't working at performance
scale and they ended up at a year to
have before they could launch arguably
had they been working with a micro
services architecture they would have
been trying to solve the problem of all
the query patterns everywhere in the
system they wouldn't try to think
upfront how do I query all this data
everywhere in five years or in a year
they would say hey I'm gonna trust that
if I need a new view into the data that
we're writing I can somehow build that
view later eventually and that's the
power of it so what we want to do is
free our mind so that we can design our
micro services trusting that we can
achieve that goal and then we have to
talk about you know how do we get there
with messages so a very brief TL DR or
you know too long didn't read in case I
have to explain acronyms on how to build
you know a pattern in design so let's
say I go to the design board for my
micro services architecture so my
company does some sort of shopping cart
selling things fulfillment
you know Amazon style and you know
customer management is a thing so these
are domains that I might tease out right
so I'm going through the design phase
and I'm saying
I've got customer management
recommendations engine product catalogs
fulfillment on the product orders
you know supply chain management
shopping carts in memory and obviously
your traditional system always has
identity of some sort right I have to
login right I have to have credentials I
have to have permissions so if we were
to take this design and say hey let's
tease out one of these domains and see
what my micro-services architecture
looks like and then how would I look at
it in an event-based view so let me take
you through that process will take
identity because it's not
domain-specific most people understand
what users do right so we have single
sign-on that's a thing inside my
identity domain right I got a login I
got a log out I have protocols
I have user management so user
management is create and activate and
deactivate users these are all things
that we do you know typically there's a
separate UI for that but it's connected
to the user store somehow right and then
we've got self-service I'm gonna
register I'm gonna confirm my email
myself I'm gonna change my own password
I'm gonna update my profile change my
email there's workflows for that so I
need UI I need api's I need you know
update my own data right and then I have
permissions in the app so now we're
starting to think about well are all
these part of the identity domain or is
permissions a separate domain don't know
let's just take the assumption that
perhaps as I'm thinking it through I'm
realizing you know I can't ease off
permissions if I have hundreds of apps
to manage the permissions for that does
nothing to do with login right I login
over here isolate it once I get to the
app what can I do right so I'll take
that out give it a different color user
profile likewise write user profile
might mean I have a membership and an
account or multiple accounts unrelated
to login its ownership of other stuff
right so maybe I tease that out
different domain and at the end of the
day what I'm trying to come up with is
what are my domains what are my
advocates behind the domain and
therefore what's my micro-services
strategy so that I can break it up into
smaller pieces so identity now turns
into three domains so it's not just
identity there's an identity domain
maybe there's a profile sub domain maybe
there's a permission
domaine so these now become isolated
things I can manageably think about
where events fit how many events I have
and each domain should own its own
messages or events meaning you never
play the same event from multiple
domains or multiple micro-services so
that makes it nice and manageable right
so now we've gone through this design
let's focus on the identity stuff so
I've got single sign-on I've got user
management I've got self-service I have
a user back-end
if that was one back-end then this is
one micro services with possibly
multiple endpoints different access
points to do stuff right but it's still
one domain because it's one back-end
right it's coupled to the data and I
could take a look at that and say hey
inside identity server if I'm using that
to build this solution so now I'm
building an app and I'm taking my design
thinking and turning it into micro
services architecture and potentially
events right so what do I need to do an
identity server I need to configure the
apps that log in so that they're trusted
and I need to do user stuff right log in
log out etc so I've got maybe two micro
services here within this environment
right
so inside identity to separate micro
services that could be updated
independently of one another with
different data store different schema
unrelated yeah and then I have these
apps that might fold in and start
sharing that API all good right so what
I'm trying to go through here is what's
the thinking that gets me to the point
that I might need to break this up and
have multiple data stores because right
now we're still in a simple environment
right it's pretty easy to imagine
services and having a user database
pretty easy to imagine having a
configuration database for trusted apps
and maybe configuring those like a UI so
we're not complicated yeah I just have
this too so I don't have an eventual
consistency story yet right so let's see
where we might get to what if I think
about this where I need to add feature
separately to user management and
self-service unrelated to logging in so
maybe I start by factoring this out a
little bit and creating well-defined
controller entry points contracts if you
will for those activities
still sharing it back-end though so that
means I'm still separate microservices
only the two and what we're trying to
get to if we need to only is this right
where maybe each of these has their own
back-end now we have to talk about why
would I care to do that what would push
me to here to where I need an eventual
consistent story in this model okay so
what would push me they're optimizing
reads so let's say I've got 20 million
users you know any number between you
know two thousand to five thousand
concurrent requests at a given point in
time on a regular basis and if I update
the containers that support identity and
login and make changes to features that
are unrelated to login I'm introducing a
fragility potentially and I'm also not
optimizing the read access for just
checking and and logging in and you know
evaluating passwords verifying right so
optimizing reads might be a reason to
separate it so that the user management
stuff doesn't have to get in the way of
this very critical piece of the central
part of my system yeah another thing
internal configuration controls so let's
say I have all these people 200 apps
this is you know example some customers
have hundreds of applications they're
managing an identity those hundreds of
applications need to be configured for
identity there is not one person doing
that there's going to be potentially
distributed people across the
organization adding their apps into the
system but they don't know identity so
we need controls we need UI we need to
keep you from running with scissors we
got to make sure you can only configure
at certain ways maybe there's three
patterns we use instead of all hundreds
that are available so we can't just let
everybody in the config directly it's
got to be controlled so we have this app
to manage that and that app has zero to
do with the runtime performance has to
do with controls which means I'm gonna
have to edit those on a regular basis
I'm going to update this on a regular
basis so I might need to separate that
from the mainstream login again to
reduce the fragility of frequent updates
here impacting this very central piece
that matters to me
so it's another reason another reason
would be multi-tenant here's an example
for identity but really I'm trying to
give you business reasons that could
come up this is identity related right I
need to update user management on a
regular basis because we have support
organization and maybe there's 300 CSRs
that go into an app and ask for features
when they ask for a future and we need
to deploy unit of deployment should I
impact the runtime login of 20 million
users should those changes and I hit the
button give me any need for concern that
I'm affecting login of 20 million users
and the answer is no so how do I break
that up the unit of deployment is I've
got an app to manage you know to manage
the users and do the CSR work and that's
got to be something they can ask for
features and the whole point of micro
services is to align with the business
capabilities these are different
business people the customers log in my
CSRs need features and now I've got
self-service as another one again
keeping to the idea that I want to
offload work I want to keep it so that
you know my customer service
representatives are not getting too many
calls from you know users having
problems so I want to update that set of
features frequently maybe as its
evolving to help them help themselves so
they don't call us and force me to hire
20 more people for for customer service
it's a real dollar thing right ok so
again looking at how you break domains
apart looking at the reasoning behind
needing eventual consistency even within
a domain potentially is about this type
of thinking if you were to pop up a
level we could just say each domain you
know I have accounts and orders and
customers might have features that I
write new data and it needs to
eventually propagate like the ledger and
account balance thing that I mentioned
before so I'm just giving you things to
think about so the goal is get to the
point where the right balance of
separate micro services and domains is
sort of outlined it's not going to be
right the first time you
evolve you might refactor it's okay
except that and the whole point of
getting a good momentum behind your
micro service deployment is that you
should not be afraid to have frequent
change right because we've got good
practices in place so the goal is to get
to the point where that right balance is
there and now I have unlocked that
achievement of having services on their
own data so I've had this free mind I
know I can eventually consistent project
data to another service back-end right
so I'm gonna just trust that I can get
there and now I have to figure out how
to get it done so let's take the example
I've given to you and let's evolve it to
the messaging part so eventual
consistency if I've got you know
independent data backends for each of
these services so these are all micro
services at this point right let's think
about now use cases so now we're going
to play use cases this is how we go
through the process within the real use
cases from config would be things like
add an app remove an app right so if I'm
gonna do that
then that will project into the config
database and eventually get into the
runtime so you know we write it to the
config database and eventually the
runtime knows hey I trust that app so
what a couple seconds later max
hopefully it's ready to go okay if I
have a register user and that means
there's a user in the database that the
customer service rep should know about
but logon doesn't need to know yet so
I'm gonna project that only to the user
management side so they can see hey user
registered but they haven't yet
confirmed their email when they confirm
their email now they're a user they
confirm their email set their password
activate and now my user runtime knows
about that user so we've projected that
over when it's time and so the idea is
that again taking these use cases we're
going to learn whether or not we're
doing this right we're gonna think about
can it be eventually consistent is it
okay of two seconds passes when I
deactivate a user is it okay the two
seconds passes and they could log in in
that two seconds before that it's
realized in the actual you know run
that's an SLA decision that's just you
know InfoSec discussion with your
security controls have we seen this be
acceptable yes because we're usually
getting sub 300 millisecond projections
and guess what the ones that are high
risk like this one we're monitoring that
carefully yeah and we have to have a
shutdown plan if it doesn't work so if
the projectors down and I can't get that
data over within my SLA then I need a
solution that can quickly execute and
shut that user off so we have to build
that into our plan for the high risk
areas only yeah the rest is we have to
trust the system will work next users
locked out well that might not need a
message or eventual consistency because
I'm only gonna write it directly to the
user runtime I type my password three
times badly I'm locked out immediately
it'll go away in five minutes there's no
need to tell the other systems there's
no projection because usually that's how
we do that today you know following the
latest of NIST and wasp okay so now
we've thought through use cases and
we've figured out if eventual
consistency feels okay for those use
cases now we're going to talk about how
we go into the message based solution so
I've got now all these api's and instead
the rights are gonna write messages so
those api's register user deactivate
register app or add app remove app those
are all going to go to a message that is
just requesting it be done and that is
gonna go to some topic right and in the
cloud that could be event hubs or
Kinesis right and then what's gonna
happen is you know config runtime well
that's really a read process right so
I'll take that away that's not
discussing messages at all we're not
doing any rights from the config API
we're just reading yeah we're doing
rights from all the other api's so those
will all have messages in place and then
what we need is a projector or a
consumer that will project the data to
their back-end so we've got this
messaging backbone that's shared across
all but we're not sharing topics right
Micra services and domains can have an
isolated topic per
and within that topic everything's in
order outside of that topic it doesn't
have to be if you need order across
topics you need things like process
managers so that's doable
in a way right if you need it but you
know you have to take the key use cases
one by one and then say do I need a
process manager or not okay so topics
nice and isolated list of messages per
micro service never sharing messages
across them so these are micro services
they have an API a set of messages a
projector and a data back-end completely
unrelated to one another the eventual
consistency story comes with how we do
seek UI reviews and things like that so
let's talk about that before I show
anything so the idea is that in a CQRS
environment right if I'm using seeker as
pattern right so I'm going to
potentially have message based rights
and those are going to make my system
asynchronous and those message based
rights can either have a right store
approach or an optimized read store
approach so let me explain that okay so
if I do a write store approach my spa or
web app is going to call a write API and
that write API is going to send a
message to the backbone and then I'm
gonna read that message I'm going to
project to a write store that is queried
on the other side okay so the idea here
is I'm actually sharing the store with
the writes and the reads I'm just making
the writes asynchronous so that there
can be a reduced back pressure of some
amount right but if I really need to do
optimized reads if we reach a point of
scale in the system I wouldn't do this
right away I would start with this
pattern until proven otherwise
so this makes it simpler architecture
right but if I see that I need to
optimize for reads because of say you
know just the maybe even the costs
sometimes the cost of a document
database the Riesz can be so intense
that you know we really need to optimize
that read store in a different way and
make the right store more I can
all right so it's costly and so if we
follow this pattern I've got requests
and respond at the API layer I've got
messages coming down and I've got
queries on the other side now let's look
at what that seems like if I have an
optimized read store I have the same
thing on the left hand side right I'm
writing messages and it projectors doing
a write to a write store but we're going
to project an event that says okay the
writes happened and now I'm going to
read that and project a read store and
there's different technologies to
support this right like in Azure we use
cosmos and cosmos has you know really
reliable event triggers for every write
and that goes to the event grid and the
event grid picks it up and then we can
do that I mean I'm making it sound
trivial it's not like a lot of time
didn't go into planning that
architecture and getting it tuned right
but it's doable is what I'm saying
because we do it so I write the topic
the event and then so now I've got
requests coming in from the web app
right I've got messages being written to
the right store and I've got events
being projected from that right so that
it's you know a guaranteed we have
written it it is successful now it is a
true fact once it's a fact it can be an
event right events are facts messages
are requests I request that you you know
add the user or or create the
registration and then the event is okay
registration was created yeah so now
registration created I'm going to add to
the read store and now the query API is
going to the read store I've now
optimized the reads okay so the queries
on that side can be highly performant
now that's just the internals right so
I'm just trying to give you a picture of
how CQRS could work in either direction
now let's talk about how it works from
the perspective of how do I get the
state of stores eventually consistent
what are some other ways right so
another way is that I can have the user
registered event or message written to
the backbone and then I can have other
interested parties to that event so a
seekers view also gives you a way to do
that
where when we write to the user
self-service that a user was created but
I'm not yet a user I haven't set my
password I'm waiting for the email right
I registered I get an email the
projector on the user management side
says I care about that message to let me
listen in on your messages as well as my
own and then I'm gonna update my data
store see so that's called a secure as
view and that pattern helps us support
another way to do the eventual
consistency without doing another event
out of the back end the decision comes
down to architectural preference and
also you know any guarantees that you
need in terms of delays to the writes
yeah so next thing over here I might
have email confirmed now I'm a user and
now I need to update the user runtime so
I'm gonna have a seeker s view pattern
there as well next thing I get locked
out well that doesn't do anything
because that's only going to the one
user runtime I deactivate a user I have
a seeker s view on both sides right so
the user self-service should also pick
that up too
I forgot to put the arrow okay now all
of this is leading to what are some of
the other value propositions and then
I'll get into a demo yeah so the other
value proposition of this whole story is
I've now created a message based
architecture whereby creating users
managing their lifecycle logging in
events are all part of an event backbone
an event based system and now I have
this really powerful piece of data
outside of my read stores or right
stores I've actually also got messages
that I can replay later to build new
protections so now the source of truth
how many people have built a history
table before for things that you needed
audit record of right like everything
that happened oh the users permission
change this day and then somebody else
change them that day and you know or you
know could be any number of things right
so audit is a big thing today compliance
regulatory requirements and what we need
is an easy way to get that done so not
that messaging
in general is easy okay right I'm used
to it I do it a lot more often with a
team obviously so you know we're having
success with that but once you've
embraced that you get the side benefit
and that is now I can project from those
messages I can go back in history and
replay those messages and build new
stores I go back to the beginning of
time and rebuild those wreath stores too
if I had to write like let's say we
change the rule on the way we process
the messages to produce the data then I
go back and I could reproject and build
the data store again and then we can do
snapshotting right for backup and
recovery and then only replay from a
certain point in time as well so these
are ideas audit and history now get to
be something that I can do for free
because I take all these message like
user created email confirmed etc and now
I have an audit list right like these
are things that happened login fail
blocking succeeded
you know audit might be more about the
activity I logged in I got locked out
etc history might be more about
permissions where elevated or reduced
right and then that's the history of my
user record so these are the things we
can do all right so we go from this
design hopefully that explains the
motivation and some of the things we
care about and we now have to apply this
plan into a technology stack so we have
to choose how we're gonna go when we go
through this process it can be different
if it's Amazon Azure it can be different
if you're using like a back-end that is
an actual event sourcing based system
like event store or eventuate i/o but if
we're just using a messaging backbone
then we do it slightly differently so
the rule of thumb that at least I
personally have seen is if you can do
pass or platform-as-a-service
anywhere that's usually really a win
because not only can they give you the
scale like cloud scale but they're
managing it for you as well so whenever
possible if we're in Amazon or if we're
not sure we're gonna use you know
Kinesis or we're gonna use event hubs
for example right could be service bus
in some cases but for streaming events
like this we usually use
event event streaming like event huh and
so a cloud technology stack might be
I've got all these you know docker
container so I need my docker platform
right I need to be able to deploy those
containers somewhere like to the AKS or
a jar kubernetes service could be a
different one in Amazon eks we're gonna
have maybe some other things like
caching so this is a path service
anything I can offload to pass win so
I've got caching I've got a pin sites
for logging so it's all built into Azure
right so I get my end-to-end tracing
almost for free almost because of course
you have to watch how you do it and see
that you can get the logs you need right
event hub for messaging and then
possibly cosmos or sequel backends and
this is another interesting thing from a
micro services perspective I can choose
if I want my back in to be sequel or
cosmos right I don't have to have the
same back-end for every micro service
depends right we have a policy server
product and that product is highly
relational and it's back in so we use
relational database schema and we've had
the odd person ask us well can we just
deploy it and put it on you know cosmos
or a different back-end and the answer
is no because like everything we do is
based on that relational schema and all
the performance testing around the
queries and so on is based on that but
that's a micro service it shouldn't
matter that this one is sequel and the
other one is cosmos and another one is
Couchbase you know it doesn't matter
it's right tool for right job per micro
service right so we can have that
freedom as well and so this would be my
cloud stack and I'm gonna deploy that
with queue control over to you know
kubernetes service those are my
containers and then I need a local story
for this so this is the other piece I
like to tell people is when we built
these systems you need a way to
troubleshoot and test this and to end
without having to all of you figure out
how you're gonna share the dev cloud
environment you know a sizable company
with lots of developers or different
teams it gets really complicated to
onboard new people and get the
productive and figure out where they
should work and that I'm using the same
messaging backbone you are and now our
messages are stomping on each other
while we test
it doesn't work so we need a local story
and that's one of the power of docker
right so I can have my docker compose up
story locally whereby I've my docker
containers running on my machine
I've got Redis you know hosted locally
in a container I've got maybe Elk
instead of app insights for local
debugging with my logs to make sure I'm
getting the right you know data in my
logs and I can troubleshoot it's gonna
make production better if I can do that
I'm gonna have Kafka maybe or event
store locally and that's gonna be my
messaging backbone when I'm testing and
I'm gonna have you know some database
that's as close as possible to what I'm
actually deploying in the cloud so
cosmos is an interesting one because
right now we don't have a container for
that that we can use with Linux
containers and because of that I can't
do you know all my Linux containers
compose up with cosmos so I have a
choice right I can either use the cosmos
tool if I have a Windows machine or if
I'm on my Mac I don't have a tool yet
and so what we do is we do provider
pattern that switches between what I'm
using on Prem or in my local machine to
let developers be productive so that
every one of you could say get pull
compose up boom it works data
initialization boom it's in there
there's a container that initializes the
database locally so that you don't have
to seed your own data to work so total
productivity gain right suite and then
you know sometimes we'll use Postgres
because that can play both sequel and
also doc database because I can use
Martin with Postgres and so will will
sometimes use that but you know this is
just one example so you need a local
story and so there I'll you know flip
over and we'll do some demo somewhere I
think I just did the wrong screen but
we'll get back there so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna go to my command here
and I'm gonna show you a couple things
so first and foremost I've got a bunch
of different scripts here and these
scripts all open them up in code but the
idea is I can run
the full kind of back end in front end
of the solution that I just described
right in containers on my local machine
if I want it debug in Visual Studio then
what I might do is something like this
to start okay so what this is going to
do is it's going to run a script that's
going to do a compose up on certain list
of things right so I'm going to do a cat
on demo back-end ps1 and what this going
to do is going to do a docker compose if
you're familiar with docker and what
that does is it runs you know creating a
network creating the Postgres backend
creating the kafka back on creating
Redis creating elke and that's giving me
my back-end now I can go to visual
studio around the front end and I can
actually debug but hit you know a
back-end that's on my local machine
instead of going to some cloud and
figuring out where to configure that
right so that's one kind of starting
point usually you'll build a bunch of
scripts for things like that so I can do
a start back-end and then this will
start those containers so now I'm going
to have it Redis and an elk and a bunch
of things
and then to point out a couple things
about that so in my LP amo for example
I'm just pulling one of the popular you
know easy to work with local containers
for Elks the full you know elasticsearch
stack with Cabana with cabana so I can
have a UI right and what that gives me
is a way to easily debug right so I can
come over here and well there it is
right so localhost 5601 so let's do that
oh it's not warning at wait wait for it
and is it running yep okay
the internet don't need it
that's interesting okay I'm gonna just
check that the docker container LS let's
just check that it's still working
because every once in a while they start
and stop right so let's see god ELQ yeah
and it's been up for fifteen whole
seconds Wow
how about we do this and I open up a new
Chrome I don't know why I'm bothering
but I'm just trying to see hang on we're
on one 5601
oh it's not ready yet
excuse me health check for the win
alright well let's let that get ready
and then I'm sure one of these moments
it'll refresh so in the meantime let's
come back over here so that's the Cabana
one I would have a Kafka one and again I
could use a vents door Kafka I'm not
saying you need to become an expert at
Kafka that's a big deal right I'm not
managing a cluster I'm not trying to do
this and to end I'm just trying to have
something locally that I can write
messages to because I can't use event
hubs on-prem right same with Kinesis so
this is giving me a story around that so
I can pull down Kafka I can run it and
then that's available for messaging
likewise with Postgres right so you know
I'm not trying to be a cop Postgres
expert I'm just trying to use you know
any framework and switch over between
local and then going to cloud or using
Martin for example so and then the PG
admin tool just gives me a way to view
that so that's my local story if you
will let me go back and see if cabañas
ready not that I was nervous okay thank
you okay so now let's talk about now my
backends running I can go to visual
studio and we'll ignore that Visual
Studio is going to give me
a way to let me close that down make it
a little room so this is my entire
solution right so I've got a bunch of
clients you know API in an MVC client
I've got consumers that are gonna pull
messages right so these guys are
responsible for pulling messages the run
time the user history and the user audit
I've got a configuration API and that's
for writing to the configuration schema
which will be a sequel in the cloud and
Postgres here I've got identity server
the web app I've got user profile which
is comprised of an API and also a web
app so the web app for for the profile
is for me to register and the backend is
going to show me things like in start-up
how do I slip between Kafka right so if
I'm Kafka then I'm gonna run here and if
I'm event hub then I'm gonna run here
you see and obviously I can provide our
pattern that in like a real production
example this is showing if-else just to
keep it kind of simple but you know the
idea would be in production in a real
sort of you know customer project we
usually make it a little bit more
decoupled and then if I look at app
settings I'm expecting my local dev to
say hey I want to use Kafka so I'm
overriding the default right and when I
deploy in a container my environment
variable overrides are going to say what
I'm supposed to do and then obviously
I'm gonna have secrets and things but
those would go outside of the container
configuration into secrets so we're
gonna have logging choices am i using
you know elastic yes I am locally and
I'm using a local Redis URL but when I
flipped a cloud I'm gonna flip it over
to cloud version of all the same right
so the idea is when I'm structuring my
apps around this one thing that you want
to make note of is having that really
strong local story and then the flip to
the cloud story
somebody should proof that right and get
it so that all the devs can use it and
then it's not like you have to reinvent
the wheel every time right once you've
got this baked it's pretty solid
so that's another thing to consider the
other is obviously you know once I'm
running a Kafka's consumer for example
so I'm gonna actually let this start
kafka consumer is going to be running
instead of event hubs and its job is to
have probably the same interface as
event hubs right what do I do with kafka
consumer I write I send messages and the
sorry the producer and then the consumer
is going to read the messages rights
likewise they got the event hubs version
of producing and consuming so you know
we're really just making it as clean as
possible so I can work locally and do
this full-blown messaging and the reason
I point that out is mostly because what
you want to do again is make sure you're
learning how to debug with your logs and
you're learning how to work the full
system you're not testing without
messages and then flipping to the dev
environment and testing with messages
from the beginning we're doing the full
story in our local machine yeah so
that's the idea so this will take a
couple seconds to load and then while
it's doing that let's talk about a
couple other things in here so I've got
the user profile web for example that's
gonna hit my breakpoint oh cool didn't
take us long so you can see that I'm
hitting my breakpoint that says hey I'm
in local so I'm gonna use elasticsearch
right so not really anything complicated
I'm just gonna give it a run so you can
see that I can run my back-end and I can
run the front-end and it kind of works
right or more than kinda so there's that
so let's see yeah it does take a couple
seconds so we've hit one great point but
a couple more seconds because it's just
slow which is why I usually debug with
docker instead just use the containers I
mean so basically now I'm hitting the
choice of Kafka so I've got a config
setting that's telling me hey go to the
Kafka version so we're gonna hit that
and then at some point here we're gonna
see our UI and then I'm going to be able
to run through an example that hits the
messaging story so while we're doing
that let me go to an example of batch so
we're going to open up a message
so here we are we're gonna send a
message that's gonna be a topic check
probably so we're gonna go and hit that
I've got a consumer that shows me the
best messages that I'm processing so
that's just going back in time and
hitting those messages that probably
were from the last run that weren't
processed yet now I'm going to handle
message but we're gonna keep going
because right now this is just topic
checks mostly and then we're gonna have
UI and it'll be in support five thousand
seven so we'll see when that's ready I'm
going to hit over here and we'll say
localhost five thousand seven
and
it's almost there okay so my UI is
running against my back-end containers
when I register user is going to send a
message to the Kafka queue right so what
I'm gonna say is Michelle boost uh I'm
gonna create an email here and we'll
call it local demo one at gmail.com yeah
and we'll go ahead and copy that
clipboard and we'll say local one boost
enter so it's going to create a user and
that's hitting again back in containers
but I'm gonna hit a breakpoint and this
is now going to try and create my
message so I have a new user
registration requested message being
generated and I'm gonna go to that
definition and just show you from a
micro services perspective right I'm
only dealing with a handful of messages
so that's all of them right now I mean
probably in the real domain it's about
you know 30 messages or something right
for that particular you know
microservice if you will right so if I
break this down by Microsoft and the
messages are manageable right I'm gonna
have a solution for microcircuits I'm
gonna have a separate API per micro
service right so that's going to be a
manageable number of events to think
about to debug against to write unit
tests for and to potentially roll out
into production right so it's just sort
of helps me to not have to think about
the whole system all at once so this is
helpful I'm gonna hit go so that's
creating that message and we're gonna
send the message so that's just see
realizing that and getting it into Kafka
and then once it's done there's going to
be a handle so we're gonna process the
message so we're pulling that and doing
a commit to the database on the other
side right so once that's processed we
now should have navigated that might
just be me not having an API running but
I think at the end what we're gonna do
is pop over here
scroll down and what I'm gonna do is
okay cool okay so right now we have only
the back hand running what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna start the front ends so I'm
gonna start the apps whole thing is
going to run locally and I can go into
end rather than hitting in Visual Studio
which is a bit slow so we're starting
now the front end user run - I forgot to
stop Visual Studio hang on got a stop
ports are being used stop that get out
of there and hit back all part of my
plan to remind you about ports cuz you
know that's important so now I'm gonna
run the containers and because I nearer
PowerShell will be red which is lovely
but it doesn't mean there's an error
anymore and this will start up all of
those containers that were in the
solution and once that's all done now I
can just go to the same port five
thousand seven and away we go so I'm
gonna go over here localhost five
thousand seven I'm not ready yet
it will be it will be it will be almost
docker container LS and we've got all of
them running profile web five thousand
seven
[Music]
refresh and it should be ready it's
thinking
who wrote that slow app okay so now
let's try it again
paste not that localhost no Michele
booster at gmail.com and Michele who's
to enter and now it will register so
it's gonna take me to a fake email page
it's gonna send a message to Kafka and
Kafka is gonna say you know the back end
consumers going to say okay we're gonna
send a message to the user we're gonna
register we're gonna write that the
registration was requested but now I'm
gonna click my link and I'm gonna go
through the process of setting my
password and we're gonna do that it's
gonna fail because I'm gonna give a bad
password and that's okay because I'm
gonna do bug with my log so I'm gonna go
over here and I'm gonna do query for
password and I'm gonna find that error
and I'm gonna get whatever that error is
and I'm gonna say hey why don't I do an
end-to-end trace so that can really
debug with my logs so I'm gonna go and
add the activity ID boom and when I add
that and take away mmm password I'm
gonna be able to see all the messages
that happened leading up to this problem
so that I can troubleshoot locally with
my logs instead of winning in Visual
Studio which was too slow anyway so now
I'm looking at all the things that
happened up to that error I'm figuring
out the problem you know if I don't like
my logs I'm gonna go fix them and add
some more intelligence so that I can
debug with my logs later and that is my
local story so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm gonna do the cloud story and so what
we'll do is probably stay in the red
screen and what we'll do is go back I
guess and then we're gonna go to connect
to my conference demo so now I'm going
to connect to my kubernetes cluster that
has the same thing deployed okay and
with that same thing deployed we'll be
able to navigate
it's not I only have a few minutes left
don't worry about it
it's the plug that's not working so he's
worried about my power okay all right so
this gonna connect to kubernetes and
while it's thinking about that we're
gonna go to Asher and we're going to go
to portal asher calm and we're gonna log
in because apparently it doesn't
remember and liar
yeah I have my phone here that's a good
thing huh I'm very secure yeah okay
all right and in the meantime kubernetes
should be launching so we're over here
yes okay it's gonna ask me to do an AZ
login really I can't believe that's
happening hey I might need another
minute
okay so yes I'm logged in good thank you
thank you are you gonna come back let's
see
yes it did cool okay so now let's try
connect not connect yes okay
I love that that just happened that's
awesome okay so it's connecting to a
cougar news cluster I've deployed that
whole solution all those containers are
running in aks I have an event hub as
the backbone instead okay so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna hit kubernetes
first and we're gonna take a look at the
identity namespace where all of these
things are deployed so you can see a
couple things real quick so in here I've
got identity and I'm gonna go to my
services right so services and in the
services we're gonna see that I have
actually I'm going to go to deployments
that's better
in this deployments we're gonna see that
I have a not-so-happy audit consumer
which means that right now if I run the
actual demo I'm gonna have a problem
with audit so we're gonna go through the
process as I just did where I'm signing
up so I'm gonna go here I'm gonna
tighten shell boost as fast as I can
nd c1 at gmail.com I have to put a real
email yeah elevation for the wind and
we'll go NDC one and we'll do boost uh
and we'll login and now I'm gonna hit
here and we're going to now have
messages going so I'm gonna go password
one two three and we're gonna login so
if I'm able to log in that means the
eventual consistent was not fast enough
for me not to be able to log in so
that's good right so we'll go there see
if I remember it yeah and now I've
logged in so good right so eventually
consistent pretty good that means I have
data if I do this Michelle booster and I
want to do maybe a different one in case
I already exist there so we'll do plus
and ec2 and we'll copy that one too and
we'll do
gusta and we'll register and we'll go
and try and confirm my email but this
time I'm gonna do a bad password and
that's okay because that's gonna be an
error next time I'm gonna try it
actually better and then I'm gonna log
in but I'm gonna fail instead so I'm
going to type that and do a bad password
a couple times and a couple more times
and I'm gonna get locked out okay and
now I'm gonna hit over here to a sure
which is where I was and we're gonna
take a look at those resources so I've
got a resource SM so I've got a resource
for where my events are and I've got a
resource for where my cosmos databases
events are coming in through here and
we're going to go to my cosmos I'm gonna
see if those things projected as
expected but I'm gonna have a history
table now
and I'm gonna have login backend which
is the sequel so that's already working
because I showed I was able to log in
right and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
hit my IKS version of user history and I
come in and query and see if I've got my
history generated from the projector
like we talked about so we'll do a this
is Kafka this is eCos
it's warm and someone here is aks
where's my egg chaos one that one good
okay so I've got user history I'm going
to query and we're gonna say execute
this one and then what we're gonna do is
this one says C underscore or C dot
actually will do star his fine and I'm
gonna say where Cu dot email or username
probably email equals and we'll paste
what I had and not hit enter and then
that should show me if I was right yeah
and ec2 or as history protecting is
probably email or username that should
be that should be there so if it's not
there then it might be because hmm
interesting
okay we're gonna do this instead a
different way I am batting a thousand
here hang on
I know Oh is it not doing the right one
oh no way
thank you pair programming is this one a
kiss yeah I love this interface okay
let's try that again
better wear seedot email equals that
yeah okay there we go
okay thank you and now we're gonna take
that user ID and we're gonna do this I'm
gonna say wear ID subject ID equals that
and that's gonna give me all the
messages that have happened including C
dot message type yeah and now you can
see all the messages that have been
projected user created log and failed
etc that's all my history fully
functioning right and so now the
interesting thing is if I do that same
query over on audit for the same user
right we're probably not going to get
anything right now but we are in about a
second
because what we're gonna do is we're
gonna head over here I'm gonna do CD
surviving I guess and we're gonna go to
identity and we're going to do a update
all and that's kind of deploy oh you've
got to be kidding me
hang on it's gonna work it's gonna go
like this we're gonna connect again it
lost the connection it does that
sometimes
and once that's connected again then
it's gonna work because that's what it
does see if it's connected ready ready
ready ready
ready I think that might have actually
done it and now we're gonna do it oh
come on really
I I hate you right now I was gonna do a
deployment so that it just fixed it
right away and instead I'm gonna have to
come here and do it because up here if I
go to my identity I can fix the audit
and it'll just work that is so weird
okay you're not gonna do it are you okay
Wow okay well audits feeling so we're
gonna just go in here and we're gonna
fix it and I'm gonna fix it by fixing
the cosmos zero there and we're gonna
update that so that's going to update
the deployment so that it's happy and it
has the right key and that means cosmos
is gonna show me fun stuff which is here
and identity here in data explorer right
there you go
oh well thank God for that okay so with
that being said I think just to close it
up here right the whole point of all of
this was to see that you could yeah
screens are fun it's
okay slides slide bugs no okay so the
whole point of that was just to say you
know we have this compartmentalization
of smaller micro-services manageable
number of messages manageable amount of
code to deal with introduced your
messaging backbone how to do eventual
consistency and have it be manageable
because of the fact that each of these
isolated have a limited number of our
messages I can focus just on the API the
projectors the messages the backend I
can count on the eventual consistency
build my projectors so the idea is I
have now this repeatable pattern a
manageable amount of things to do in
each and you know after that we're gonna
deal with additional you know thoughts
right additional concepts like snapshots
message replay polling and replay
message versioning Poisson message
handling preserving order which I said
is per domain or pore mica service if
everything can't be eventual we can deal
with those cases on a case-by-case basis
and then we need our drills and alerts
and monitoring around it for the
sensitive areas to make sure that they
played on time so yes it's a lot of work
but the benefit on the other side should
be that you can project and have your
audit in your history for free have
visibility into the system and then I'm
gonna just say I'm out no pain no gain
thank you
and that was painful